you know something happened to liberals
who are fellow liberals yes
um and whatever it was yes accelerated
and Amplified during the pandemic I was
not on board with how we handled covid
what was your Evolution when did you say
a long time ago I was I was on 16
minutes quoted me like in 20 2009 or
something saying uh I wouldn't get a flu
shot one thing I don't understand about
the covet thing is how come I mean I'm
sure you know about the Great Barrington
letter that was signed by 16 000 doctors
and scientists who were all dissenting
about how we were handling it how come
your doctors only count I'm not talking
to you I'm talking to the Western
medicine how come your doctors they're
the ones that's the science so I know
you watching that are like yes duh but
you're still voting for the wrong people